hi I'm Ron aphelion artists is to
managing editor of Time magazine and I'm
here in Davos Switzerland for the World
Economic Forum 2012 I've just used to
viewing professor muhammad yunus who is
a laureate kind of the Grameen Bank and
the father of microfinance about how
companies can play a greater role in
social business there's a big debate
going on right here what about the
responsibilities the public sector and
private sector who should be shouldering
the burden returns of unemployment debt
etc professor Yunus additionally felt
that the private sector should take a
greater role in solving social
challenges obviously that's why Canada
from a bank and if you'd like to see
companies doing more with social using a
social business is something in design
as a business doesn't run solely to
problem solve with all dividends going
back into the company so this could be
around issues like health education
spoke about it adventure the clan
meeting had with Donna the large
friendship and consumer products company
when they're making and distributing
yogurt in poor countries for nutritional
value to improve nutrition and help
reduce food poverty in vulnerable
populations come it's interesting
because it really fast the brushing of
very cool what business is due to take
on responsibility preventing water
purification healthcare education how
much is too much I think it's a very
interesting question because there are
some here in the maternity that's giving
the state sector a cast that we're
letting the state over by pushing
business to take up some of these
challenges are also different conflicts
of interest website covering delivering
water and also selling water probably on
this division between companies and
countries is inimical really interesting
detail i gota forwarding certainly were
here a lot more about throughout any
Karen thank you so much okay Thank You
Simon I was not really